[Musica]
buongiorno buongiorno a tutti buongiorno
lo dico più volte perché siete veramente
in tanti è un bell effetto che fa essere
qua sopra
parleremo di un qualcosa che è
estremamente dibattuto è stato dibattuto
da persone decisamente più interessanti
di me e con cultura maggiore
cercheremo di fare in un modo diverso
con una prospettiva diversa cercando di
farli entrare all'interno della nostra
prospettiva che quelle di dover prendere
decisioni in frazioni di secondo e più o
meno il tema di questa giornata a 0 0
secondi e quello che deve essere il
nostro modo di prendere decisioni in
quasi istintivo quasi una cosa
meccaniche siccome ho degli amici molto
carini alla tende io sono abituato a
fare delle partite che durano
tendenzialmente 90 minuti mi hanno detto
due solo 15 minuti di tempo per poter
fare questa breve presentazione 15
minuti di tempo è per me un fattore di
pressione non semplice per voi una
garanzia che almeno non vi annoierò più
di 15 minuti
ci sono due cose in italia davanti una
platea che non bisogna mai fare un e
parlare di politica difficile l'altra
parlare di calcio
riuscire a parlare di calcio con voi
quando noi siamo l'unica squadra al
mondo che non ha tifosi anzi di solito
siamo bersagliati di tifosi di per sé
anche questo mette un po che pieno sotto
pressione
ed è per questo che voglio partire un
pochettino da lontano avevo 13 anni
quando ho deciso di fare l'architetto ho
sempre avuto questa passione in realtà
ho scelto 13 anni perché sono entrate
una kauter cartolerie ho visto luci
colori penne le i fogli l'odore del
foglio l'odore della gomma quando vi
ricordate quando entrava te nella
cristalleria c'era ancora l'odore della
gomma
li ho deciso io voglio fare l'architetto
il mio percorso la mia carriera
formativa sarà per fare architettura da
grande voleva imparare le regole
dell'architettura per mettere in
difficoltà gli ingegneri sapete che gli
architetti vogliono sempre costruire
qualcosa di strano costruire degli spazi
che poi dopo dc ma come fanno a stare su
e gli ingegneri ti dico nella struttura
a struttura non è importante perché per
noi la cosa più importante del mondo e
regalare emozioni trasmettere emozioni
il mio obiettivo era far modo che una
persona in trascinano spastici s wow
oppure per ora comunque un'emozione far
lasciare un segno far qualcosa per le
persone che nel momento in cui entravano
dentro dicevano bello io ero molto
ambizioso e il mio obiettivo era
lasciato un segno dell'architettura
italiana e ovviamente per questo che
faccio l'arbitro però questo dualismo
tra la figura dell'arbitro figura
dell'architetto mi è sempre rimasta
abbastanza dentro nel cuore nel mio dna
da una parte c'era la volontà di
conoscere di imparare il più possibile
dall'altro far rispettare le regole che
voi imparato è un binomio che
tendenzialmente in antitesi però nel mio
caso andato abbastanza di comune accordo
da una parte volevo creare spazi luoghi
dall'altro la volontà di controllare gli
stessi luoghi stessi spazi
essenzialmente il mio obiettivo era
creare e controllare emozioni da una
parte una cosa molto rigida dall'altra
una cosa molto più dinamica e divertente
questo questo controllare le mozioni era
un modo anche per poterle vivere farle
vivere e allo stesso tempo
l'obiettivo principale di un arbitro è
cercare di gestire le emozioni
questo binomio immediatamente sin da
piccolo quando io a 15 anni ho deciso di
fare l'arbitro di calcio e ci vuole
veramente una forma mentis particolare
perché non so per quale motivo e non mi
sono ancora dato una risposta del perché
l'ho fatto
però ti mette di fronte delle realtà
molto particolare questa fotografia
rappresenta benissimo quella che è la
mia prima parte della carriera da una
parte architettonica perché sono un
architetto può fare un campo in un'isola
una cosa come questa molto particolare
dall'altra parte la solitudine
dell'arbitro l'arbitro è una persona che
è abituata a parlare da soli in campo
mettetevi all'interno di un campo 22
persone 21 persone che seguono un
pallone incoronato un pallone tukory
dietro 22 persone che seguono un pallone
è una cosa già di per sé abbastanza
particolare devi trovare un modo per
gestire anche i tempi morti perché
all'inizio c'erano tantissimi tempi
morti mi ricordo che quando dovevo
decidere
ero in difficoltà la prima partita per
un fallo laterale
fallo laterale voleva dire la palla è
uscita è stata toccata per ultimo dal
giocatore blu il giocatore blu attacchi
in quella direzione io indico di là
perché e diventa anche questo un micro
meccanismo
che doveva avere una razionalità dietro
e il tutto ho capito subito che mi
creava tensione e per questo io cantavo
durante le partite nel tempo ovviamente
aumentando a rifiutare le partite queste
canzoni sono diventate parole domande
più domani mi facevo che mi davo
risposte fino a chi è pian pianino non
mi sono trovato nelle partite un pelo
più complicate quelle che mi hanno
creato i primi problemi quelli che hanno
cambiato il mio approccio alla partita
vela descrivo brevemente questo è un
esempio è successo davvero peraltro
avevo vent'anni mi trovavo la domenica a
dover andare a berceto provincia di
parma quando il sabato sera tutti i miei
amici erano nati al mare in discoteca
divertirsi passione sacrificio difficile
mi ritrovo in questa partita dove c'era
pioggia freddo tanto freddo situazioni
difficili in campo giocatori che
protestavano pubblico che mi insultava
dal primo minuto ancora prima che
iniziasse insieme in campo la tensione
che imboccava le gambe probabilmente era
anche il fango perché sapete quando la
scarpa nel fango fai fatica a muoverla
non so se era il fango la tensione
insomma finisce il primo tempo tra
insulti perché c'era una richiesta di
rigore allontanato l'allenatore
situazioni difficili
non vedo l'ora di entrare nei suoi
authority della particolare ma chi me
l'ha fatto fare
e alla domanda peggiore che uno può fare
nel momento in cui sta facendo proprio
lavoro vuol dire che è fuori contesto in
quel momento freddo io ho sempre
sofferto il freddo da morire
in quella partita ho detto io smetto io
prendo vado a casa e non torna non
faccio neanche il secondo tempo non
smetto
invece qualcosa è scattato qualcosa
della volontà di reagire
la volontà di andare oltre all'ostacolo
io non mollerò mai dentro di me mi sono
tolto la maglietta solo una maniera di
ricambio ovviamente sbagliando presa con
la maniche corte
bene vado in campo decido di non sentire
il freddo di divertirmi di guardare il
gioco e di vivere le cose in maniera
diversa in comincia il secondo tempo non
sento il freddo a maniche corte non
sento fair mi rendo conto dopo pochi
minuti non sento il freddo non sento la
pioggia aveva smesso di piovere peraltro
quindi forse anche per quello
però mi rendo conto che la
concentrazione l'approccio il modo di
vedere le cose cambiavano quello che era
il mio sentimento e allora ho capito che
ci sono delle emozioni che purtroppo
influivano tantissimo sul mio modo
d'essere c'erano c'era una parte di
stress che influiva tantissimo su quello
che era il mio modo di essere allora
imparare questa cosa è un pochettino
anche mettersi a confronto con le
persone che di solito ci criticano tutti
quelli che mi offendevano si offendevano
o comunque vedono l'arbitro sempre come
un nemico e noi non siamo nemici non
capiscono una cosa fondamentale
questo è un proverbio spagnolo che dice
non è la stessa cosa
parlare di tori che essere nell'arena
essere l'arena è diverso essere un arena
c'è lo stress che incide tantissimo su
tutto quello che fate
sul posto di veder modo di vedere le
cose sulle vostre emozioni che
influiscono sulle vostre decisioni e
soprattutto sulla vostra il vostro modo
di reagire
quindi sono deciso di fare un qualcosa
per me stesso di studiarmi conoscermi
conoscere anche le dinamiche di gioco
per poter prepararmi in maniera adeguato
questo è una partita di calcio
io simile però provate a fare un
paragone la presa di calcio ovviamente
ad alti livelli e come se fosse un
equazione di 100 variabili con 100
variabili e voi dovete risolverla in un
minuto
impossibile l'obiettivo di un arbitro è
esattamente il contrario risolvere tutto
prima di vederlo se noi su 100 variabili
ne conosciamo prima di scendere in campo
50 l'equazione più semplice se di queste
50 appena comincia la partita ne capiamo
altre 20 diventa tutto molto più
semplice questo è il nostro obiettivo
conoscere per prevedere e prevedere vuol
dire riuscire a fare le cose meglio
senza essere senza incappare nell'errore
a questo punto la domanda che mi fanno
più spesso di tutti è quanto coraggio ci
vuole a scendere in campo a prendono
decisioni fischiano un rigore magari una
finale di champions league
come ho fatto e ho fatto senza avere
tutti gli elementi per valutare linea
macchia di gioco conoscenza dei
giocatori esperienza tutta una serie di
variabili che son riusciti a preparare
per riuscito a preparare prima
dell'evento quanto coraggio ci vuole
zero la decisione non è mai una
questione di coraggio il coraggio ci
vuole nel prepartita quello sì l'ansia
l'attesa la prestazione con una
questione di coraggio di gestione delle
emozioni in realtà il coraggio non non
c'entra nulla sulla visione una
decisione solo frutto di aver fatto una
procedura corretta quando noi a casa
abbiamo fatto di tutto per prepararci
conoscere giocatori mentalmente
atleticamente e fisicamente in campo
abbiamo fatto di tutto per scegliere la
prospettiva migliore perché per noi è
fondamentale
dopo la visione una conseguenza e delle
volte può anche essere sbagliata
questo ti dà la forza di superare anche
gli errori allora qual è la cosa che
definiamo il nemico dell'arbitro è una
cosa un po particolare quello che noi ci
frega di solito è l'effetto sorpresa
tutti voi dite di solito non me
l'aspettavo non ero preparato è una cosa
è sopraggiunta all'improvviso l'effetto
sorpresa è quello che non puoi prevedere
allora a questo punto una questione di
capacità capacità di agire vuol dire
prevedere riuscire a fare le cose
reagire nel momento in cui siamo
sorpresi l'istinto l'obiettivo di un
arbitro e fare in modo che l'istinto
diventi una cosa razionale meccanica vi
faccio un esempio c'è qualcuno che sta
guidando buca una gomma in autostrada ai
160 all'ora
questa persona distinto di capacità o
comunque di esperienza magari riesce a
controllare la macchina e parcheggiare
un'altra persona
scoppia la gomma stessa situazione va a
sbattere e istinto ma un istinto si può
comunque razionalizzare farsi in modo
che ci siano all'interno alle spalle di
questo un ragionamento meccanico e
istintivo questo è il nostro obiettivo
vi faccio un esempio per farvi capire un
pochettino meglio quello che è capitato
l'esperienza con cui ho anche imparato
nel tempo e le varie situazioni
semifinale quarti di finale di champions
league atletico madrid barcellona è uno
una delle partite più delicate
l'andata era finita 2 1 per il
barcellona
quindi c'era la possibilità di ribaltare
di fare eccetera
partita difficile giocatori molto il
conoscete magari chi di voi gioca a
calcio li conosce gli allenatori
estremamente difficili da arbitrare
io ho fatto la partita migliore della
mia vita migliore della mia vita fino ai
minuti di recupero il mio di recupero
dopo che ho preso tanta decisione votato
anche un rigore giustamente di recupero
c'è una situazione particolare che io
vedo controllo ma mancavano veramente 10
secondi fallo di mano di un giocatore
chiaro messo in posizione bene fischio
dal fallo di mano guardo ve sono i piedi
i piedi sono fuori dall'area di tanto
così fuori area
proteste non proteste dopo due minuti
partita finisce
vado negli spogliatoi arriva
l'osservatore che abbiamo tutti i
partiti dice purtroppo era dentro oggi a
proposito di quello che dicevamo prima
un secondo con l'avaro la tecnologia mi
direbbe che dentro
l'errore più grosso della mia vita l'ho
fatto nel momento in cui ero convinto di
aver finito la partita nel momento in
cui sembrava tutto perfetto
noi viviamo purtroppo all'interno di un
corridoio dove tutto sembra perfetto voi
considerate questo come un corridoio
paragonabile alla pre di calcio 300
situazioni 300 camere dell'albergo nelle
quali dovrete aprire la porta guardare
valutare prende decisioni a chiudere la
porta
detta così sembra anche facile l'albergo
anche bellino peraltro quindi non
mettiamoci un po di pressione mettiamo
paragoniamolo al corridoio di shining ci
mettiamo davanti la bambina col triciclo
e questa bambina il tempo voi dovete
seguire la bambina che andrà più veloce
più lentamente questo è il tempo della
partita e dovete prendere tutte le
decisioni con la velocità in cui la
bambina va avanti si può fare
indubbiamente si può fare trecento
situazioni di cui 150 quasi nulle 50
riguardano il fuorigioco
una cinquantina a calci d'angolo falli
laterali eccetera
trenta sono quelle che voi fischiate i
falli che decidete di punire di questi
30 1 cambia la partita e si è fatto un
errore dietro c'è jack nicholson col
coltello che non vede l'ora di metterlo
nella schiena questa un pochettino alla
partita 300 situazioni all'interno del
quale voi dovete sapere che dalla prima
all'ultima non vede
ora di mettere il coltello e jack
nicholson rappresenta tifosi mass media
tutti quelli che ovviamente odiano le
persone che prendono decisioni
nessuno di loro ha mai capito che noi in
realtà siamo persone normali allora
calma ci sono momenti in cui è troppo la
nostra preparazione si chiede troppo
controllo di qua controllo di là
ripartiamo controlla ciò che poi
controllo che poi un pochettino il mio
mantra quando facevo delle partite che
erano troppo impegnative e mi rendevo
conto che la tensione rischiava di
essere un pochettino cerchiamo di
riportare il tutto a livello
proporzionato il controllo che poi è una
cosa molto importante allora oggi
siccome ha parlato di quelle che sono le
difficoltà dell'arbitraggio vorrei fare
un pochettino un gioco con voi chi lo
vuole fare che non lo vuole fare può
benissimo non farlo però vorrei portarvi
all'interno dell'unico momento
divertente di un arbitro che il
prepartita all'ingresso in campo il
momento più bella dell'arbitro e quando
l'arbitro prende il pallone
io di solito lo baciavo per sentire
prima di tutto lo do re mi ricordava
quando ero bambino che accudiva il
pallone rotolavo fra le mani sentivo
l'odore e vi voglio portare con me in
questa esperienza quindi se abbassiamo
le luci chi lo vuole fare
chiude gli occhi ascolta la mia voce e
li riaprirà nel momento in cui senti
tifosi siamo in brasile stadio maracanà
che solo il nome credo che rappresenti
la storia credo che tutti voi conoscete
quello che è il modo di giocare dei
brasiliani il divertimento dei
brasiliani nel giocare a calcio siete
all'interno dello sport dello
spogliatoio estate salutando i vostri
colleghi gli assistenti e gli dite
divertitevi
perché la cosa più importante quando
scendiamo in campo e divertirsi
aprite lo spogliatoio vi dirigete verso
il tunnel e ci sono schierate le due
formazioni germania sul lato sinistro
argentino il lato destro stanno per
scendere in campo per giocarsi la finale
della coppa del mondo
poi guardate la ma alla vostra sinistra
e di the good luck e lui vi dà la mano
alla vostra destra c'è messi lì
stringete la mano e ditte suerte e vi
rendete conto che loro sono talmente
talmente concentrati su quello che il
loro obiettivo vincere quella maledetta
piccolina coppa del mondo che in quel
momento nonostante sia alta venti
centimetri rappresenta il centro
dell'universo tutto il mondo sta
guardando questa partita
loro non rappresentano loro stessi
loro rappresentano una nazione un popolo
per l'argentina addirittura vincere la
coppa del mondo in brasile sarebbe una
cosa grandiosa strepitosa guardate
avanti anche voi
davanti alla coppa del mondo c'è il
pallone il pallone che tra poco
prenderete in mano e rotolerà sul campo
del maracanà me
[Applauso]
[Musica]
quello
divertitevi
sempre grazie
[Applauso]